nous sommes escorté vers la ligne de
front sur de petites routes de campagne
les soldats du bataillon karpatz kasich
nous emmène sur leurs bases au sud
disions une vie d'aujourd'hui tenus par
les russes et
leur unité contre quelques centaines
d'heures chargé de freiner l'avancée des
blindés ennemis
les temps qu'eux n'ont pas la moindre
chance contre sa
frappe la tourelle et il n'en reste plus
rien si tu sais utiliser des armes avec
un bon instructeur tu peux vraiment
apprendre rapidement
karpatz kasich est l'un des nombreux
bataillon nationaliste créé en 2014 à
l'époque de maidan ces volontaires sont
aujourd'hui intégrés aux forces armées
ukrainiennes
leur unité est chargé de freiner
l'offensive russe au nord ouest du
dombass son chef lance un appel aux pays
occidentaux
dont toutes postées il y à des tirs
d'artillerie en permanence sur nos
positions dans les temps que nous tirent
dessus aussi mais on tient bon on a
besoin de plus d'armes antichars je veux
adresser un message à tous les pays
occidentaux nous avons besoin des deux
nous avons des armes mais il faut nous
en donner plus aidez nous à vaincre
notre ennemi juré qui s'en prend aux
fondements du monde civilisé
c'est désolant titre
nous remontons à la surface pour voir
les positions ukrainiennes allaient
dépêchez vous mais des drones russe
survolent la zone pour guider les
frappes il faut alors s'abriter chez des
habitants de ce village situé en
première ligne les déflagrations toute
proche
ne provoque aucun mouvement de panique
on s'est habitué ça fait deux mois que
ça dure vous ne vous mettez palabres et
si parfois quand ça devient trop dur il
n'y a que les fous qui n'ont pas peur
quelques minutes plus tard les frappes
se rapproche
mettez vous à l'abri
on avait des armes plus puissantes pour
les atteindre on pourrait
contre-attaquer mais pour l'instant on a
trop
on essaie surtout de tenir nos positions
pour les empêcher d'avancer
nous profitons justement d'une accalmie
pour visiter les positions de cette
unité
plusieurs tanks sont dissimulés grâce à
la végétation
d'été 72 qui date de l'ère soviétique
notre armement est trop vieux pour
livrer une guerre moderne il me faudrait
l'artillerie et les temps pays de l'otan
dispose c'est de ça qu'on rêve on a
besoin pour gagner c'est à dire
avant de gagner la guerre il faudra
d'abord sauver le dombass l'armée
ukrainienne ne tient plus qu'une infime
partie de cette région
est à propos justement d'une basse les
forces russes sont entrés dans la ville